[Musique]
j'aurai mon temps mais je rigole pas
allez vas-y c'est fait c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa taille
tu attends
[Applaudissements]
on aura un combat avec moi j'ai un
gastaldi bien sûr fin juin s'il n'a pas
un accident mais bon
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les champions en titre
[Musique]
lors je ne sais pas le boucher cacher de
mamie ouate îles habibas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux m'occuper de lui pendant la pub
j'ai encore lu m une thalasso
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que j'y suis allée fait un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il fait un plaisir tant en ville alors
je peux pas te suis bien notés sur
pavillon
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chevilles je rappelle je rappelle le
hashtag cascades y est une banane
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors franchement où on peut faire
ça ou on monte un ring alors quand même
porte pour vous sachez en fait cyril
c'est un amour de mecs mais alors quand
il joue à quelque chose la nuit tombe ou
côté second depuis ce matin on iv
premier degré et dont et dans
l'affrontement qu'on a c'est sûr de rien
qui était en fait une vitrine à la taxe
devait tomber dans un trou et compte de
chocolat bien évidemment voilà en fait
j'ai en fait je reçois un coup et je
pense et je pense le pauvre et je
m'excuse auprès de lui que c'est youssef
qu'il a mis un coup sur la tête et en
revoyant les images le mec qui m'a sommé
comme sur un buzz
en fait il peut pas il peut pas faire ça
pour pour de rire quoi c'est tout mon
père me salis voilà il faut qu'ils y
aillent il faut qu'ils y aillent il faut
qu'ils mettent des récentes années mais
moi imaginer imaginer que je répliqué
que j'y fasse mal autant moi si je suis
pas là un jour j c'est lui il a quinze
jours de rtt sera problème